one of the things I'm fascinated by with
the animated process is how much things
can change from when you first start to
what people are going to see on screen
so with Addams Family how dramatic were
the changes along the development
process
there weren't incredibly dramatic I mean
we we had the story that we wanted to
tell
so that actually remained pretty
consistent throughout I think one of the
biggest dramatic changes was the villain
we had some crazy ideas for the villain
that were really fun but they it just
kind of became the villains movie and so
we had to pull back a little bit on that
but as far as the atoms are concerned
it's like we have such a rich history to
look back on that we just wanted to make
sure that we stayed true to who they
were completely and there were so many
great - a lot of of the cutting room
floor material we would have loved to
have kept in the movie but you know
there's just so much share great stuff
there that you can do with this family
so that sort of again the movie dictated
itself as we went through the process so
but there's a lot of that there's a lot
of cool like takes what would you how
can you describe like obviously you do
test screenings or friends and family
screenings how much of that stuff ended
up being like animated to a point do you
know what I mean or when does it
actually get cut out of the process we
we screened really really early on all
storyboards at one point is that weird -
does the audience can they can they take
it in it's tough it's tough
it was tough and what we really needed
to take out of that screening was where
the slow pork parts were and where we
needed to speed it up a little bit and
what jokes weren't hitting we couldn't
really take as a cohesive story you know
people's you know we just want to make
sure that they weren't confused but at
that point and then we had another
screening where we actually had a bunch
of layout in there which was rough as
well so we didn't get a really good
sense about where we were you know with
an audience until we had a lot of
animation in and that's usually where
people start to screen animated movies
is when you know
when you can make sure that the audience
isn't confused and you can make sure
what jokes are hitting and what aren't
but isn't one of the things I love is
the way she walks without moving her
legs yeah you know what I mean
can you talk a little bit about that and
how it's just fun yeah I mean that was
when we pitched that idea to the
animators they were concerned about how
she was going to walk and we actually
look back to how Carolyn Jones walked as
the 1960s Morticia and I of course you
can see her legs move in her dress but
she had a very distinctive way of almost
lighting across the floor and then had
the little tentacles that come off the
bottom of a dress would you sort of made
them wiggle around a little bit almost
like a dress is carrying her around it
was just a nice little you know
stereotypical thing from what is she to
do is is very her we did some tests
where she was going up and down stairs
so we got to see those octopus like
tentacles go down the stairs and up the
stairs and it's pretty fun I'm always
curious one of the things I love about
animated movies also as you can include
Easter eggs that maybe people will never
see unless you pause it and really study
are their Easter eggs in it a lot of
Easter eggs in there for people that
were fans of the original charged atoms
as well as all the the other iterations
we kept our heart - quite a lot of that
so in there if you look for a fish I
will say this because a lot of people
probably won't even know this but
they're I would just say because it was
a thing started out as in the Charles
Adams cartoons this is just a shadow in
the background it wasn't a hand in the
original it was just a shadow with two
eyes blinking in the background of all
his cartoons so there are a few places
in the movie where we've stuck him yeah
but I won't tell you where not right is
there any scene that people you let's
give away one is there any scene that
someone should really like it look a
little like a little hint and where to
look when Morticia and Gomez are talking
to Wednesday about school okay now don't
leave it there see if you can find I
know one of you did some voices for this
movie I forget what I was counting right
right so how did you cherry pick what
you wanted to do
in the film did you have to run it by a
certain other person no I mean we we
have scratched dialogue which is before
the actors come in we go ahead and you
know throw voices down just to see how
it's playing to the storyboards and if a
voice just kind of clicks and hits then
we just say well why don't you just do
this
you know I'm sag I've done voices before
so they said well this will be an easy
one too you know to go so we they
actually took my voice and pitched it
way down for lurch
and and it seemed to fit fine so we just
kept it in and he looks like yeah
casting what was the last thing that you
cut out of the film for whatever reason
before locking picture oh I think it was
just like a line I think it was yeah it
was we had with Margo the the villain of
the movie and we had two or three
different endings for her as we were
trying to figure out which one would be
the best play out and so there were a
couple of those endings that hit the
cutting room floor for sure yeah but up
until like mixing we were putting in new
lines and taking out old lines and you
know just really looking at things and
making sure that we are getting the best
of what we could so completely um if I'm
not mistake yourself X for a quick
second on a a sequel or spin-off with
sausage party is that sort of is it ever
gonna happen do you think it's pretty
much I think it's if it happens it's not
gonna happen in the traditional way I
don't think we want to make just a
straight-up sequel sure I believe you're
involved with Jetsons I am right I I
grew up watching The Jetsons where are
you at in that process really early
stages and there was only one season of
The Jetsons believe it or not that's
Cretan as a kid you don't realize now
it's just like I think there's only like
12 or 15 episodes total and you grew up
on it and you just don't realize it
you've probably watched them all six or
seven times but we're in really really
beginning early stages of that um if you
two could guess direct something what
would you like to guess direct
uh-oh god that's a tough one I would I
can't be specific but a horror movie
would be fun or horror TV show during
something like that would be pretty neat
I haven't worked in and I loved working
on this you know for the the creepy
aspect of it and I'm a huge horror movie
fan so you know like a like a walking
dead or something like that be pretty
cool for me it will be any 1950s based
movie so like American Graffiti type
movie I would love to direct something
like that so cool
my last thing do you have a favorite
ride at Disneyland uh yeah I think it
would probably be shoot there's so many
running through it I'm just gonna say
Space Mountain that was what I was gonna
say you know say that - space and I'm
terribly sorry I gotta go
congratulations thank you right now
thank you so much for giving me your job
hey thank you